Kim Kardashian's loved ones react to her  scary incident in Paris where she was  robbed at gunpoint on Tuesday Caitlyn  Jenner broke her silence sharing a  heartfelt Instagram posts about Kimmy  that read love my girl after hearing the  full story I'm so thankful she's okay  it's a reminder for us all to be careful  in the uncertainty of this world while  the I am Cait star showed empathy for  her daughter's traumatizing experience  crawl Lagerfeld offered this blunt  reaction after she was robbed of over  eleven million dollars worth of jewelry  he told The Telegraph quote I don't  understand why she was in a hotel with  no security  you cannot display your wealth and then  be surprised that some people want to  share it with you still Karl appears to  maintain a good relationship with the  Kardashian family and even wrote Kim a  special message before his Chanel show  in Paris on Monday writing we are all  with you  you